bien sûr que les bien prendre place
d'accueillir ce matin Monsieur Emmanuel
Levacher qui préside arcus pour échanger
sur les perspectives ouvertes par la
prochaine loi de programmation militaire
merci monsieur le Président d'avoir
accepté cette audition vous êtes
évidemment le bienvenu je crois que
c'est même la première fois que vous que
vous venez chez nous
alors depuis un an la guerre du crâne
bouleverse évidemment le contexte
géostratégique européen la demande
d'équipement terrestre militaire
s'accroît sur le continent où la
concurrence on peut le dire est très
vive au sein de ce secteur
en France nous n'avons pas encore le
projet de LPM mais nous n'avons pas
nous n'avons pas entendu pour le moment
que le secteur terrestre il soit très
prioritaire en tous les cas c'est les
informations qui qui nous parviennent
dans ce domaine le centre de gravité de
l'Europe pourrait bien se déplacer vers
l'est vous nous direz si vous craignez
les conséquences à long terme de cette
évolution pour l'industrie
française de défense arcus est en effet
directement concerné en tant
qu'entreprise intermédiaire du secteur
terrestre je rappelle carcus
issu des entreprises Renault Trucks
Défense aqmat et Panhard est entièrement
implanté en France mais des tenu
maintenant par le groupe suédois Volvo
votre entreprise est partenaire du
programme scorpion qui est un programme
central pour l'armée de terre et dont
nous sommes évidemment attentifs au bon
déroulement on a eu l'occasion à
plusieurs reprises notamment à satori
d'en voir des démonstrations tout à fait
éloquentes est-ce que vous ne craignez
pas que la prochaine LPM Rev sur les
objectifs et les échéanciers actuels ce
qui serait paradoxal dans le contexte
que nous connaissons je rappelle que la
précédente LPM visait notamment
accélérer le programme scorpion hors des
informations qui nous parviennent les
accroître justement l'idée selon
laquelle on ralentirait maintenant
le développement du programme scorpion
arcus fournit par ailleurs les porteurs
du système César fameux canon qui fait
beaucoup parler de lui en bien du reste
les commandes se sont accélérées cette
année dans un contexte de livraison à
l'Ukraine
30 systèmes en dotation dans l'armée de
terre ont été où seront livrés à
l'Ukraine
le gouvernement souhaite accélérer
considérablement la production pour
procéder à leur remplacement et donc
vous nous direz quelle mesure vous avez
prises pour répondre à cette attente et
quels sont les enjeux pour vous
notamment en termes de maintenance de
livraison à l'Ukraine d'équipement
produit par votre société le
gouvernement a lancé un chantier relatif
à l'économie de guerre expression qui
nous paraît démesurée au regard des
moyens pour l'instant qui sont mis en
oeuvre vous nous donnerez votre
sentiment à ce sujet et vous direz quel
est votre regard sur le fonctionnement
et les résultats des groupes de travail
mis en place d'une manière générale
qu'attendez-vous de la prochaine LPM
mais aussi des financements européens
pour pouvoir répondre au défi qui se
présentent à nous et faire en sorte que
notre pays soit prêt à affronter les
crises futures voilà quelques mots
d'introduction pour ouvrir le débat je
vous propose donc de vous donner la
parole puis après une présentation
générale mes collègues compléteront mon
propos avec un un dispositif de
questions
rappel que cette audition est diffusée
sur le site internet du Sénat sur le
Président vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
d'abord je vous remercie pour votre
invitation c'est un honneur et un
plaisir pour moi de pouvoir m'adresser à
votre commission et partager
effectivement les éléments d'actualité
des éléments de réponse aux questions
que vous avez évoquées monsieur le
Président dans votre introduction déjà
très complète ce que je vais faire si
vous permettez c'est une rapide
présentation d'entreprise et des grands
enjeux et puis ensuite plutôt procéder
plutôt par réponse aux questions que
bien sûr vous souhaiterez me poser alors
sur la présentation d'entreprise et
quelques défis auxquels nous avons à
faire face d'abord l'entreprise
effectivement appartient au groupe AB
Volvo à ne pas confondre avec Volvo Cars
qui est qui maintenant est une société
indépendante donc vous voyez quelques
chiffres sur ce groupe qui a un groupe
international 42 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires l'an dernier des sites de
production dans plus de 18 pays un
certain nombre de marques et vous voyez
d'ailleurs parmi ces marques de camions
essentiellement d'engins de construction
Renault Trucks puisque effectivement le
groupe Volvo avait racheté Renault VI en
2001 donc ça fait déjà 22 ans au à
Renault et donc Renault Trucks Défense
faisait partie de Renault Trucks de la
corbeille de la mariée à l'époque et
ensuite a été réorganisé au cours des
années avec effectivement les
acquisitions que vous avez citées de
Panhard dakhmats et pour devenir en 2018
arcus sous un seul toit
le groupe Volvo est un groupe en fait
très décentralisé je vous montre ça sans
rentrer dans le détail mais juste pour
exprimer et illustrer le fait que nous
sommes en fait organisés par différentes
Business Unit enfin unité d'affaires
arcus est l'une d'entre elles et nous
sommes donc une filiale à 100% du groupe
et mon patron direct c'est le président
du Groupe Volvo voilà donc on a à ce
titre là une grande autonomie de gestion
de stratégie une autonomie de nos moyens
mais aussi une responsabilité évidemment
quant aux résultats attendus par cet
actionnaire qui est un actionnaire
unique
arcus en tant que tel donc comme vous
l'avez évoqué c'est une entreprise qu'on
pourrait qualifier de taille
intermédiaire
à peu près 550 millions de chiffre
d'affaires l'an dernier 1500
collaborateurs dont une bonne partie de
techniciens d'ingénieur âge moyen 40 ans
24% de féminisation on espère et on
travaille à augmenter d'ailleurs ce taux
et puis ensuite comme vous le voyez une
certaine dynamique de de RH puisque nous
embauchons 150 personnes par an en
moyenne nous avons maintenu aussi ces
flux de recrutement malgré les années
covid et comme vous l'avez mentionné
effectivement une implantation 100%
française donc avec des usines on va le
voir tout implanter en France et
également un réseau de fournisseurs qui
est extrêmement important pour nous qui
est en très grande partie française
alors nous sommes un partenaire
historique j'allais dire et stratégique
peut-être mais en tout cas historique de
l'armée de terre puisque nous
fournissons à peu près tout ce qui roule
sur des roues à l'armée de terre soit
seul soit en partenariat avec en
l'occurrence surtout Nexter vous voyez
les flottes en service actuellement que
ce soit les flottes de VBR de PvP
develra de VAP de camions de toutes
sortes et puis également les vbcis et
les Césars que vous avez évoqué
également nous participons au programme
scorpion ebmr donc c'est à dire Jaguar
griffon avec des volumes va y revenir
qui a priori sont toujours maintenues en
termes de cible et également nous sommes
le fournisseur des véhicules des forces
spéciales et des VT4 dont le programme
d'ailleurs est arrivé en fin de
d'exécution pour la production
la LPM effectivement la LPM actuelle a
un impact très important pour nous et
irrigue l'activité de nos différents
sites industriels que vous voyez
réparties sur les territoires français
avec Saint-Nazaire où nous avons en
particulier produit les VT4 mais où nous
régénérons en ce moment des VBM Limoges
qui est un site historique de Renault
également où nous assemblons les kits de
mobilité pour griffon et Jaguar et nous
avons aussi des activités plus générales
d'assemblage de véhicules pour l'export
Marolles-en-Hurepoix dans l'Essonne où
nous réalisons les tours et l'eau du
programme Scorpion et également des
organes nous fabriquons des organes
mécaniques pour le programme scorpion
entre autres et puis garchisie à côté de
Nevers ou nous avons une activité de
logistique pour l'ensemble de la pièce
de rechange pour nos clients mais en
particulier pour le programme scorpion
mais également de fabrication de caisse
blindées et de régénération de vape
nous sommes également et c'est très
important de le garder en tête un acteur
important du soutien du MCO nous avons
en particulier donc bon 10000 camions
5000 blindés que nous entretenons
régulièrement que ce soit des poids
lourds des vagues des engins pan art ça
représente 40% de notre chiffre
d'affaires 2022 200 millions d'euros
essentiellement pour la France mais
également avec un flux qui est à
destination de l'export
et parlant d'export donc nous avons des
zones de d'exportation qui sont
concentrés sur les sur les territoires
que vous voyez à l'écran donc Europe
Afrique du Nord Moyen-Orient Afrique et
également Asie du Sud et du Sud-Est
principalement
donc où nous avons
au gré des des programmes possibles et
actuels donc un certain nombre de flux
exports qui sont parfois un peu plus
erratiques que le les programmes France
vous voyez aussi s'afficher à certains
nombre de pays sur lesquels nous avons
soit désactivés en cours soit des
prospects très sérieux y compris des
zones que vous avez évoquées monsieur le
Président d'Europe centrale et orientale
Estonie République tchèque Ukraine
Roumanie et suède également
alors
l'actualité les défis pour une
entreprise comme la nôtre effectivement
acteur de la bêtisier des terrestres
on a effectivement beaucoup parlé
d'économie de guerre
je pense pas qu'on soit complètement
encore dans une économie de guerre mais
clairement l'industrie a été sollicitée
pour montrer de la réactivité réagir à
la demande finalement pour dire les
choses simplement de produire plus plus
vite et moins cher
donc avec effectivement une notion de
mobilisation de l'industrie pour pouvoir
répondre à ces sollicitations nous avons
participé à un certain nombre
d'activités réunions groupes de travail
ces travaux sont encore en cours
ce que ce qu'on peut dire en tout cas
pour ce qui nous concerne c'est que nous
n'avons jamais cessé d'ailleurs de
d'investir sur nos sites pour les
moderniser pour les rendre plus
efficaces nous n'avons jamais d'ailleurs
cessé de d'être actif sur l'ensemble de
des activités encore une fois de
fabrication mais aussi de réparation des
matériels et également de solliciter
notre propre chaîne d'approvisionnement
qui est souvent d'ailleurs le sujet
critique là où se trouve souvent des
goulots d'étranglement pour bien
répondre assez sollicat sollicitations
vous avez cité en particulier une
relance un petit peu de l'activité César
pour laquelle nous fabriquons les
porteurs on parle de ces armes 1
c'est-à-dire la génération actuelle donc
effectivement nous fabriquons en ce
moment 36 pour être précis 36 porteurs
pour le compte de Nexter qui est notre
donneur d'ordre en l'occurrence et
effectivement nous avons réactivé des
chaînes de d'assemblage une chaîne
d'assemblage qui se situe à Limoges pour
fabriquer ces porteurs avec des délais
un petit peu raccourcis nous avions
anticipé en fait certaines
approvisionnements de matières premières
et de composants pour pouvoir raccourcir
un peu ses délais et ensuite essayer de
monter en puissance si vous voulez on
pourra revenir en détail sur ces
questions puisque c'est un bon cas
d'école de la difficulté de relancer en
fait des des productions de matériel qui
avait cessé d'être fabriqué en l'état et
de réactiver les chaînes
d'approvisionnement pour des volumes qui
restent bien sûr ils sont bienvenus mais
qui restent somme toute limité en valeur
absolue
voilà et nous essayons en tout cas
d'être toujours force de proposition de
proposer des solutions pour pourquoi pas
du matériel sur étagère du matériel
régénéré plutôt que neuf etc donc
pourraient essayer d'accompagner la
volonté du ministère des armées et de la
DGA de simplifier aussi ses propres
processus d'acquisition de simplifier
les spécifications des matériels
demandés et donc on est en tant que ti
un petit peu on essaye de faire preuve
d'agilité et de
proposer des solutions qui sont parfois
plus rapides ou plus de notre point de
vue plus efficace que des très grands
programmes à effet majeur qui parfois
sont un peu surdimensionnés pour
certains matériels terrestres
pourra revenir dans le détail bien sûr
sur ces questions alors en termes de de
paysages de justement de programme
actuels et futurs voilà ce qui ce qui
aujourd'hui est sur la table avec bien
sûr des éléments qui sont encore
mouvants et qui nous
qui nous intéresse et parfois nous
préoccupe donc évidemment les livraisons
scorpion donc qui normalement doivent
s'étaler donc jusqu'à 2030 voir un petit
peu au-delà effectivement comme je
mentionnais les cibles en volume
semblent confirmer en revanche
effectivement mais sans qu'on en est non
plus la certitude il se pourrait qu'il y
ait des des
étalement ou en tout cas des des
lissages de certains volumes de
production de scorpion dans la future
loi de programmation militaire ce qui
évidemment n'est pas une bonne nouvelle
pour les entreprises du secteur mais
encore une fois ce à quoi on pourra on
pourra
ensuite on n'est pas impliqué
directement dans ce qui concerne les
chars bien sûr puisque c'est bien sûr
nos collègues de nexters qui sont
leaders sur ce sujet mais clairement
c'est aussi dans le paysage
programme majeur qui aussi pose un
certain nombre de questions
concernant des activités qui nous
concernent directement donc c'est les
autres programmes qui avec un risque
aussi de décalage ou d'étalement le
renouvellement des camions des camions
tactiques et logistiques de l'armée de
terre avec une première tranche qui
concernera les citerniers des 6 derniers
de nouvelles générations donc pour
lequel un appel à candidature a été
lancé pour jusqu'à 800 véhicules mais
sûrement des tranches
progressives donc c'est qu'une partie
une petite partie de ces de ces flottes
qui est enclenché du renouvellement ses
flottes qui enclenché pour le moment
ensuite le programme vbae qui est
extrêmement important pour nous qui donc
le véhicule de de blindé d'aide à
l'engagement qui remplacera le VBL donc
que nous attendons aussi dans la
prochaine loi de programmation militaire
donc le développement a été enclenché
grâce à des financements européens du
Fonds européen de défense pour des
briques technologiques qui devraient
après entrer dans ce futur vbae et là
aussi nous attendons bien sûr que le
programme français ou franco-belge
puisse s'enclencher pour avoir cette
perspective et puis ensuite d'autres
matériels qui sont critiques pour
l'armée de terre en tout cas l'engin de
génie de combat qui qui est aussi dans
le dans la perspective de la future LPM
et également les premiers appels
d'offres concernant des robots donc qui
devrait également arriver et qui sur
lesquels nous pensons nous positionner
donc effectivement le la question plus
pas mal mais sans qu'on ait d'éléments
très
enfin très très concret aujourd'hui
c'est très clair c'est est-ce que
ces programmes vont être maintenus dans
la future LPM est-ce qu'ils vont arriver
dans des délais qui nous permettent
d'envisager de l'activité de
développement et de production dans un
délai assez proche donc on peut avoir
quelques inquiétudes sur le fait
effectivement que ce soit considéré
comme moins prioritaire que d'autres
secteurs donc on peut comprendre
d'ailleurs
dont on peut comprendre qu'il soit
remonté en haut des priorités compte
tenues des du contexte
du contexte
géopolitique voilà ce que je voulais
partager avec vous en guise de
d'introduction et pour planter le décor
et maintenant je me tiens à votre
dispositions pour des questions
alors
qui Cédric Perrin tout d'abord
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président merci pour cette
exposé et merci pour la qualité du
matériel que vous que vous nous
fournissez on a souvent l'occasion de se
rencontrer dans le cadre du p146 moi
j'aurais quelques questions
principalement la LPM que nous sur la
dans laquelle nous sommes engagés
actuellement et évidemment énormément
LPM qui permet une remontée en puissance
dont la trajectoire budgétaire et pour
personne ne peut le nier a été jusque-là
respectée
il serait évidemment peu compréhensible
pour moi qu'on allonge davantage encore
les délais de certains noms de matériels
qui commencent à arriver et qui sont des
matériels particulièrement performants
mais quelques messages peu rassurants
malheureusement filtre sur le segment
terrestre dans le cadre de la future loi
de programmation militaire il y a
beaucoup de bruit qui qui circulent
malheureusement pour le moment ce ne
sont évidemment que des bruits mais si
toutefois les programmes majeurs sont
réduits comme ça a été dit par le
président à l'instant pour scorpion ou
pour les camions le remplacement des
camions pardon il faut évidemment
compenser
et cela évidemment en faisant durer le
matériel davantage que ce qu'il aurait
peut-être dû durer initialement pour que
les équipements puissent performer plus
longtemps il sera donc nécessaire
d'amputer peut-être mais malheureusement
le p146 pour alimenter le p178 ce que je
ne souhaite évidemment pas du tout parce
que ça nécessiterait évidemment de faire
des choix et de faire des choix sur du
matériel nouveau que nous ne
commanderons pas tout ça pour permettre
à l'armée de terre de conserver ses
capacités et à l'industrie et vous êtes
bien passé pour le savoir de continuer à
avoir de l'activité pour pouvoir durer
également ça n'est évidemment de mon
point de vue pas du tout la meilleure
des solutions mais en toute à cause ce
n'est pas évidemment celle que nous
souhaitons mais est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en parler nous dire comment vous
envisagez les choses et surtout est-ce
que vous pouvez nous faire une
évaluation alors à la louche parce que
évidemment je pense que vous n'avez pas
les éléments mais du surcoût que tout
cela générer parce que évidemment quand
on prolonge des programmes quand on les
repousse ça génère des coûts très
important pour
industriel mais aussi surtout pour pour
le budget de l'État est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire quelques mots et
puis vous n'avez il y a un sujet qui
n'est pas abordé celui de la taxonomie
c'est un sujet qui de plus en plus nous
est remonté par un certain nombre de
l'industriels divers et variés au début
c'était des PME ensuite les ETI
aujourd'hui les grands groupes
commencent à y être particulièrement
confrontés c'est un sujet d'inquiétude
dans cette commission est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire quelques mots est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des difficultés
à trouver des financements ou est-ce que
ça comment est-ce que vous vous
entrevoyez en tout cas la suite compte
tenu de ce que nous entendons même si
malheureusement on aurait pu espérer
qu'avec la guerre en Ukraine ce sujet
serait aurait fait l'unanimité contre
lui merci beaucoup
merci Cédric Olivier sigoletti oui merci
monsieur le Président juste une question
monsieur le Président concernant le MCO
terrestre le ministre des Armées que
nous avons reçu il y a quelques semaines
ici même nous confirmait une évolution
dans le cadre du p178 alors mon collègue
a évoqué le p-146 pour ma part j'ai
aucune le p-178 auquel je suis plus
sensible et le ministre nous a annoncé
une augmentation notamment du MCO terre
dans des proportions conséquentes est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui arcus est en ordre de
marche pour pouvoir faire face à
l'augmentation de ce MCO terrestre sur
les différents sites que vous avez
présentés
deuxième question vous avez évoqué le
programme scorpion dans le cas du
programme scorpion nous avions eu à
évoqué ici même le programme camo qui
est un programme intergouvernemental
avec nos alliés belges comment est-ce
que ce programme impact vos chaînes de
production
avec des délais
identiques au livraison française ou
est-ce que c'est c'est des livraisons
sont toujours décalés comme il était
prévu à l'origine malgré l'arrivée de la
crise sanitaire et puis enfin un élément
que vous n'avez pas évoqué monsieur le
Président il s'agit du scarabée
qu'en est-il aujourd'hui du scarabée
est-ce que vous avez trouvé un pays
susceptible d'être le démonstrateur sur
ce véhicule
promis un bel avenir et enfin est-ce que
vous vous pensez toujours que le
scarabée pourra à terme équiper l'armée
française merci monsieur le président
merci Olivier Yannick beaugrenard
oui merci monsieur le Président
du l'occasion de
visiter l'entreprise arcus sur sur
Saint-Nazaire qui est en face de
recrutement du reste vous avez dit tout
à l'heure monsieur le Président il
fallait produire plus plus vite et moins
cher et du coup dans ce cadre là j'ai
deux questions à vous poser
la première avec Pascal et Lizard dans
le cadre du programme 144 on regarde
souvent les difficultés que peuvent
rencontrer nos entreprises dans ce
finance pour leur financement ou le prix
financement du matériel qu'elles ont à
réaliser parfois sous la pression de ONG
et les banques hésitent compte tenues de
l'image qui pourrait empathir selon elle
de préfinancer du matériel financier du
matériel militaire c'est ma première
question la deuxième dès lors que vous
êtes en face de recrutement semble-t-il
assez conséquent est-ce que vous
rencontrez des difficultés de
recrutement et de quel ordre merci
merci Yannick Renan le gueux
si monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président en décembre 2017 le chinois
Gilly détient enfin devient le premier
actionnaire de Volvo par l'acquisition
de 8,2% du capital
en conséquence Gilly détient 15,6% des
droits de vote qui était détenues
jusqu'à lors par le Fonds
capital dans AB Volvo est-ce que cette
prise de participation du chinois Gilly
a des conséquences depuis pour
l'entreprise arcus je vous remercie
merci Renan François Bono
merci monsieur le président
oui vous travaillez actuellement avec le
laboratoire Ibis que a développé des
technologies de d'optimisation
énergétique sur les véhicules blindés
est-ce que vous pourriez nous en dire un
peu plus
merci Pascal à Lisa
oui monsieur le Président merci ma
question portera aussi sur les
problématiques de financement vous
présidez monsieur le Président un grand
un grand groupe j'imagine que vous êtes
peu exposé à ces problématiques de
financement mais mais j'irai dans votre
dans votre chaîne de fournisseur dans
votre supplay chain est-ce que vous avez
connaissance de difficultés de
financement
quelles sont les solutions que vous
pouvez apporter et pensez-vous qu'il
serait bon de légiférer ou réglementé ou
de contraindre un peu plus
les acteurs financiers sur ce sujet
merci
merci et moi je voudrais compléter les
questions de mes collègues par une
question qui concerne un peu l'export et
notamment le programme scorpion c'est un
programme beaucoup plus sophistiqué que
les matériels qui équipent nos forces
armées françaises on sait très bien que
et notamment il y a beaucoup de
connectivité il y a beaucoup de
technologie excessivement performantes
or on sait que pour une une chaîne de
production puisse tenir sur le long
terme le seul marché français et l'achat
des armées françaises ne suffira pas à
assurer le remplissage du carnet de
commandes si j'ose dire est-ce que vous
ne pensez pas que la sophistication et
le degré avancé de technologie mis en
oeuvre dans le province scorpion que
nous avons tous découvert notamment à
satori et qui est un équipement tout à
fait extraordinaire en termes de
performance mais est-ce que ce n'est pas
un handicap pour des politiques
d'exportation vis-à-vis de pays qui
n'ont peut-être ni les moyens financiers
ni j'allais dire l'environnement
technologique pour en assurer
l'exploitation je dis ça par rapport à
au rapport que tel ou tel d'entre nous
les visites que nous avons fait que j'ai
fait moi-même en Corée de nos collègues
qui reviennent Indonésie etc où l'on
voit de nouveau pays émergents en
matière d'industrie de défense qui vont
produire beaucoup plus ont beaucoup plus
grande quantité souvent moins cher des
équipements beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
simple peut-être mais qui reste
évidemment des des concurrents vis-à-vis
de pays j'allais dire de la tranche
intermédiaire qui ne pourraient pas
s'équiper de matériel aussi sophistiqué
ce Président vous avez la parole pour
répondre à toutes ces questions
merci monsieur le Président merci pour
toutes vos questions
donc je vais les prendre dans l'ordre où
elles ont été posées
alors effectivement
remonter en puissance
certes on va y revenir par rapport donc
à cet articulation entre 146 et 178
c'est-à-dire entre fabriquer du neuf et
entretenir ou réparer des flottes
actuelles effectivement pour nous pour
nous qui sommes sur les deux les deux
sujets
on espère et on pense et en toute
logique qu'il y a une sorte de vaste
communicants en toute logique si on
remplace plus lentement les matériels
par des matériels neufs et bien il
faudra faire vivre plus longtemps les
flottes actuelles et donc les réparer
davantage les entretenir davantage
éventuellement les régénérer c'est une
de nos spécialités effectivement nous
avons régénéré je parlais tout à l'heure
de régénérer le VBL nous avons régénérer
un certain nombre de matériel que ce
soit les vagues les camions GBC etc
vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs dans votre
question pour nous c'est critiques c'est
à dire c'est aussi la condition pour
qu'on puisse durer et qu'on puisse
continuer à charger nos usines en
attendant évidemment que l'ensemble des
programmes 9 soit réalisé donc non
seulement c'est souhaitable mais c'est
clairement quelque chose qu'on va
surveiller de près puisque c'est pas
forcément évident qu'il y ait une
translation automatique de ce qui n'est
pas fait en 146 dans les le 178 et puis
ensuite il y a un autre curseur qui est
important pour nous dans le
l'utilisation du 178 c'est qu'est-ce qui
est fait ensuite par les entités
étaniques la Sims le sanitaire etc
qu'est-ce qui est confié aux industriels
donc quel degré de sous-traitance là
évidemment c'est aussi un curseur que
que qui est important à pour nous de
maintenir un certain niveau de
sous-traitance ce qui de toute façon
correspond à une certaine logique
puisque les moyens techniques et humains
des institutions éthiques sont aussi ce
qu'elles sont et donc limitées donc le
complément apporté par l'industriel
privé doit rester
au niveau actuel donc pour répondre à
votre question encore une fois non
seulement c'est souhaitable mais mais
c'est quelque chose qu'on espère et sur
lequel on sera vigilant
puisqu'effectivement il n'y a pas de
garantie absolue de cette translation
puis on compte sur vous aussi pour pour
faire en sorte qu'effectivement
les
ses moyens soient maintenus
sur la taxonomie alors
certes c'est une forte inquiétude de
notre part c'est plus qu'une inquiétude
c'est une réalité qui devient de plus en
plus
pressante on a peut-être connu un très
léger assouplissement au moment de
de l'effet de choc de de du début de la
de l'invasion russe en Ukraine mais on a
assez vite vu que finalement les choses
revenaient à une tendance
comment dire à pointer du doigt à
l'industrie de défense comme étant nom
durable et donc ça cette tendance là
elle elle subsiste elle continue à se
développer c'est effectivement un danger
pour la pérennité de l'industrie de
défense au travers du financement mais
pas uniquement c'est-à-dire c'est
l'ensemble en fait des acteurs qui sont
susceptibles finalement de de participer
à l'industrie de défense qui peuvent
se retrouver un petit peu comment dire
ostraciser exemple c'est un exemple
assez édifiant donc un salarié qui ne
peut pas obtenir
un crédit immobilier de la part de sa
banque parce que il travaille dans une
entreprise de défense donc ça va très
très loin ça peut aller très très loin
alors c'est peut-être aussi des des
exemples un petit peu isolés mais qui
montre en fait l'ampleur du phénomène de
la pression que cette industrie subit et
qui est effectivement assez malsaine
puisque
décrété que l'industrie de défense est
pas durable c'est un petit peu
incompatible avec la nécessité de
la de la faire durer et puis surtout de
la faire monter remonter en puissance
alors sur le MCO terrestre le p178 la
montée du MC au terre donc j'ai dit de
façon générale évidemment qu'on le
souhaite à presque nous sommes en état
en ordre de marche pour faire face à
cette éventuelle surcroît de demande la
réponse est clairement oui pour si nous
concerne on a investi d'ailleurs
spécifiquement dans certains de nos
sites industriels pour faire face à
cette remontée en puissance du du
soutien et du MCO terrestre on a
spécialisé notre usine de Saint-Nazaire
dont donc à 100% dans des activités de
réparation et de régénération et on a
également créé un hub logistique pour
tout ce qui concerne la pièce de
rechange dans notre usine de Garchizy à
côté de Nevers où nous faisons aussi les
les revalorisations de VAP donc on nous
sommes capacitaires nous pouvons faire
beaucoup plus que ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui et on peut dire que nous
sommes en or de marche alors bien sûr
ça suppose aussi que toute la soupe la
chaîne suive c'est parfois là que on
peut avoir faire face à quelques
difficultés
faut aussi réaliser l'âge de certains
des matériels que nous entretenons et
réparons donc pour fournir des pièces de
rechange de vape ou de ou de GBC 180 il
y a parfois quelques sujets liés à
l'obsolescence de certaines de ces
pièces mais c'est notre job de de gérer
en fait ces obsolescences de trouver de
nouveaux fournisseurs ou voir de
proposer des nouvelles solutions qui
passent y compris d'ailleurs par des
nouvelles technologies comme
l'impression 3D pour pour compenser en
fait ces obsolescences
donc la réponse est clairement oui sur
ce que nous sommes en ordre de marche
pour
concernant camo effectivement alors
c'est d'abord un commentaire général sur
Camon c'est pour nous c'est vraiment une
excellente
un excellent montage qui qu'on espère
voir se reproduire peut-être dans pour
d'autres pays européens ou partenaires
de la France
donc c'est aussi parce que pourquoi
parce que c'est vraiment l'alignement
des planètes entre les besoins enfin
entre les les opérations militaires les
opérations d'achat et statique et puis
bien sûr les industriels donc on a en
fait finalement une un exemple qui
marche en tout cas de coopération
européenne sur des matériels alors
qu'ils sont évidemment calqués sur le
matériel français ce qui ce qui est
parfaitement interopéra parce qu'il est
ce qui est plus facile effectivement
donc la production camo ne sera pas
décalé par rapport à ce qu'elle a été
par rapport au plan initiaux mais elle
approche maintenant à grand pas puisque
la première production de griffon voilà
seront démarré en 24 mais surtout se
réaliser en 25 donc on commence à
pouvoir intercaler plutôt donc les
productions camaux dans les productions
scorpion France comme prévu alors si
scorpion France s'étale un petit peu
bien salé sera encore un peu plus de
place pour camo mais voilà en tout cas
ça ça on est très très évidemment
enthousiaste sur ce programme sachant
que non seulement bon il a toutes les
qualités que je viens d'écrire mais
surtout il offre et aussi des
perspectives de nouvelles briques avec
pourquoi pas vbae et d'autres matériels
dans le futur
alors scarabée effectivement j'en ai pas
parlé c'est c'est un démonstrateur de
nos technologies qu'on avait déjà
présenté à eurosatori en 2018 donc c'est
déjà un petit peu ancien mais
effectivement on continue de le
développer continue d'en faire la
démonstration nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui un pays client comme
particulier qui pourrait
l'adopter puis ensuite le
le tester en conditions réelles mais
évidemment on continue à travailler à
cette à cette option là est-ce qu'un
jour il sera adopté par la France telle
qu'elle je ne crois pas aimer en
revanche c'est clairement une base sur
laquelle on peut s'appuyer pour y
compris tester un certain nombre de
d'idées de technologie de concept qu'on
reprendra en partie dans dans VBA mais
VBA sera certainement différent de
scarabée ça c'est pour être très clair
alors Saint-Nazaire oui enfin suite à
une visite à Saint-Nazaire et
effectivement produire plus plus vite
moins cher quand j'ai parlé de cela
c'était ce qui nous est demandé c'est
l'injonction
du président et du ministère des armées
bien sûr nous faisons tout pour répondre
c'est pas toujours
si simple plus ça peut vouloir dire
effectivement éventuellement un peu
moins cher mais à condition que les
volumes soient significatif aujourd'hui
on n'est pas forcément sur des
augmentations de volume ou des volumes
très significatifs plus vite ça dépend
effectivement aussi de notre capacité à
anticiper éventuellement à stocker
certains composants certaines matières
pour produire ensuite plus vite mais qui
dit stocker ou acheter ou prendre le
risque d'acheter en avance un certain
nombre de composants dit effectivement
financement comment on se finance
comment on peut supporter à l'échelle
d'une entreprise comme la nôtre ce genre
de surcoussis évidemment difficile et
compliqué et en tant que chef
d'entreprise responsable vis-à-vis de
ses actionnaires de ces résultats on
peut pas non plus s'engager dans des
prises de risques inconsidérées là
effectivement intervient le la question
du financement
et du soutien qu'on peut obtenir du
système bancaire ou financier en général
pour ce qui nous concerne effectivement
on n'a pas trop trop de sujets pour
l'instant puisque on n'a pas vraiment à
faire appel aux banques pour financer
notre activité
à quelques exceptions près quand même
qui sont souvent les les financements
pour l'export ou l'intervention des
banques pour des opérations export sous
forme de garantie de caution etc et là
effectivement on rencontre quelques
difficultés pour obtenir ce soutien sur
des ouvertures de garantie par exemple
pour des opérations export de la part
des grandes banques de la place où on
est obligé d'aller chercher des banques
un petit peu plus locales ou parfois
exotique donc ça c'est c'est vrai que
nous sommes moins touchés que beaucoup
de nos fournisseurs ou peu plus petites
entreprises et ça fait l'objet d'une
autre question que sur lequel je peux
donner quelques éléments tout de suite
c'est effectivement
nous sommes nous nous voyons un certain
nombre de nos sous-traitants
fournisseurs faire face à de grandes
difficultés c'est des difficultés
d'ailleurs qui sont souvent dues au
contexte économique général inflation
problème de rupture d'approvisionnement
et effectivement ils ont d'autant plus
de difficultés à participer à l'effort à
anticiper et pourtant c'est là que ce
serait le plus nécessaire puisque en
fait c'est toute la Supply chaîne qui
doit qui doit se mobiliser pour pouvoir
accélérer donc là il y a une sorte de
quadrature du cercle dans entre des PME
des petites entreprises fragilisées par
l'environnement général par le fait que
les banques sont moins peut-être moins
allantes sur la défense et de plus en
plus sollicité pour pour prendre des
risques pour pour anticiper etc donc on
est on est confronté
un peu comme souvent mais bon là
peut-être de façon peut-être extrême à
ce qu'on appelle les injonctions
contradictoires qui parfois peuvent
stresser le système
et effectivement on a un certain nombre
de fournisseurs qui ont des grandes
difficultés alors la question était
posée de quelle solution
il y a un certain nombre de fournisseurs
qu'on est dans direct par exemple on
leur paye directement l'achat de leur
matière pour qu'ils puissent fabriquer
les composants qui ensuite entrent dans
la fabrication de nos produits parce
qu'ils ont des difficultés très
orientées etc donc on peut intervenir
directement sur cette forme là mais on
peut pas le faire systématiquement et ça
fait pas une habitude à prendre mais
effectivement de temps en temps on est
obligé d'intervenir pour les aider à
financer leur achats et leurs besoins
fonds de roulement
est-ce que
il y aurait la possibilité de légiférer
là-dessus alors je sais c'est plus
voilà moi je sais pas spécialiste du
travail législatif mais mais clairement
ça ça pourrait aider est-ce que ça
suffirait à tordre le bras des banques
ou je sais pas très honnêtement dans la
mesure où c'est système bancaire ils
sont soumis ou ces banques ces grandes
banques elles sont soumises aussi à des
législations qui sont pas forcément que
françaises et aussi à des contraintes
commerciales ou qui sont aussi plus
globales que local mais si c'était
possible évidemment on le on le on le
enfin ce serait ce serait bien venu
alors je remonte à la question était
posée sur l'actionnariat du groupe Volvo
donc effectivement le Gilly qui est déjà
propriétaire de Volvo Cars avait pris
une participation en 2017 dans AB Volvo
il faut savoir que Jilly chez AB volvo
est un actionnaire certes relativement
important en taille relative même si
c'est pas le premier actionnaire il y a
un autre fond suédois qui est qui est un
peu plus de de poids mais c'est un
actionnaire relativement discret voir
passif et et je peux dire très très
clairement et sans aucune en toute
transparence il n'a aucune prise sur
l'activité ou la gestion d'une activité
comme la nôtre et même d'ailleurs du
groupe Volvo autant que je puisse le
voir en tant que membre du comité
exécutif du groupe donc
pour l'instant enfin en tout cas pour
l'instant
c'est pas c'est pas une une contrainte
ou ou un problème
enfin actif ou concret bon c'est c'est
de notoriété publique donc c'est pas
quelque chose non plus de secret donc à
suivre mais pour l'instant ça n'a pas
d'incidence sur notre activité notre
gestion
alors notre domaine l'optimisation
énergétique dans les blindés alors ça
c'est un vaste sujet effectivement j'en
ai pas parlé dans mon exposé introductif
mais nous avons un certain nombre de
d'activités d'innovation et de de
recherche avancée sur de nombreux sujets
dont celui de l'énergie donc comment
finalement optimiser mais aussi comment
trouver des nouvelles sources d'énergie
pour les matériels de défense comment
aussi faire en sorte que le blindé
lui-même produise et stock plus
d'énergie pour opérer les différents
systèmes qui sont de plus en plus
consommateurs d'énergie et lui donner
aussi des capacités opérationnelles
nouvelles on pense bien sûr à
l'électrification et à l'hybridation des
chaînes cinématiques nous l'avons fait
donc par exemple dans ce scarabée c'est
natif on le on l'a proposé sur griffon
pour faire un griffon hybride et là
l'idée c'est bien sûr d'économiser
l'énergie mais aussi de donner plus
d'autonomie nos véhicule et surtout plus
d'autonomie électrique pour opérer de
façon silencieuse certains nombre de
systèmes d'observation voire d'armement
donc effectivement oui c'est un domaine
dans lequel nous nous travaillons nous
investissons nous faisons des
démonstrateurs avec la DGA et avec nos
partenaires industriels et nous
continuons d'ailleurs à rechercher des
nouvelles solutions donc électrification
sur batterie mais aussi utilisation de
l'hydrogène pour pour pourquoi pas comme
carburant ou comme carburant pour des
fuels donc tout à fait c'est un domaine
important de de recherche et de
perspective intéressante
alors sur l'export
alors oui tout à fait d'accord avec vous
monsieur le Président et d'ailleurs
c'est un thème que nous mettons
régulièrement en avant c'est-à-dire se
décalage entre la sophistication des
matériels développés sur cahier des
charges français et parfois la demande
du marché international qui n'est pas de
ce niveau soit que effectivement les
véhicules soient trop sophistiqués ou
trop compliqués à utiliser ou tout
simplement trop cher à l'acquisition et
à l'utilisation donc c'est un classique
je pense dans dans la façon dont
les grands programmes d'armement
génèrent alors bien sûr ça tire vers le
haut en termes de technologie mais ça
génère aussi un surcroît de
sophistication alors nous chez arcus on
a répondu à ce problème depuis très
longtemps parce qu'on a développé en
parallèle des programmes français des
gammes qui sont plus destinées à
l'exportation et dont les
caractéristiques principales
effectivement sont une certaine
rusticité une certaine simplicité
d'utilisation
[Musique]
ou des accords d'état à état et c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué beaucoup plus
coûteux à monter quand on peut faire les
deux en parallèle c'est l'idéal mais
évidemment pour un industriel de taille
intermédiaire comme nous ça veut dire
aussi gérer beaucoup de diversité
différentes gammes de produits et ça
veut dire aussi peut-être un peu de
complexité là plutôt en termes de
gestion
alors oui pardon j'avais une question
également sur les difficultés de
recrutement éventuels en tout cas
effectivement nous recrutons
régulièrement
différents niveaux aussi bien dans nos
bassins d'emploi vous avez eu autour des
usines qui sont pas forcément tous des
bassins d'emploi facile soit qu'il soit
très compétitif comme Saint-Nazaire soit
qu'il soit un petit peu
restreint comme Nevers ou Limoges et
nous rencontrons effectivement des
difficultés différents types de
difficultés d'abord la concurrence rude
sur le marché du travail pour les
métiers d'ingénieurs et de techniciens
sur les bassins d'emploi très dynamique
évidemment comme la région parisienne
donc là c'est j'allais dire la guerre
des talents donc dans laquelle
évidemment bon
faut se battre mais le donc la
difficulté de recrutement c'est plutôt
lié bien la difficulté de de mais qui
est de notre
ressort de d'être attractif pour les
talents et puis ensuite de leur offrir
aussi des conditions de travail et de et
un environnement qui les qu'il est
retienne et puis dans certains bassins
d'emplois pour les personnels ouvriers
ou opérateurs là c'est parfois plus des
problèmes quantitatifs avec capacité à
avoir suffisamment de candidats sur des
sur des postes et alors et aussi les
compétences donc pour se faire
d'ailleurs nous avons développé en
interne des écoles de métiers où nous
formons nous-mêmes les les candidats y
compris peu qualifier au métier
spécifique qui nous intéresse la
mécanique la soudure etc voilà donc
effectivement quelques difficultés mais
avec toujours des solutions et il faut
se battre
notre collègue vivait de Lopez oui merci
monsieur le Président juste une petite
question j'ai vu sur votre carte tout à
l'heure que vous étiez en partenariat
avec Oman pouvez-vous nous dire quel
n'est-il très précisément parce que
comme nous devons faire un petit
déplacement là-bas j'aurais aimé avoir
un petit peu des renseignements merci
alors how man effectivement nous avons
une relation
existante avec avec Oman ils ont des
flottes de VBL et également plus
récemment acheté des véhicules pour
plutôt maintien de l'ordre sécurité qui
sont des algares donc des gros camions
blindés nous sommes actuellement
discussions avec
Oman pour la régénération des VBL sur le
modèle de ce que nous avons fait pour la
France et également pour des achats de
nouveaux matériels dans la suite de ces
matériels de maintien de l'ordre pour
donc des remplacements
Oman et c'est un
client et un pays intéressant
du point de vue de j'allais dire du
suivi de la fidélité et nous avons aussi
des activités de de MCO et de vente de
pièces de rechange et puisqu'ils
entretiennent très bien leur leur flotte
et leur matériel donc c'est un client
j'allais dire très sérieux et récurrent
et avec lesquels on a bâti une relation
de confiance donc on espère bien et on
pourra vous donner peut-être avant la
mission encore plus de détails et des
points très précis sur sur ce qui
éventuellement vous pouvez nous aider à
apporter comme discours en tant que
fournisseur français
Cédric Perrin voudrait reprendre la
parole sur une question
de mon propos je vous interroge sur une
évaluation que vous pourriez faire pour
l'entreprise et pour l'état du coût du
surcoût lié à la prolongation des
programmes parce que ça c'est évidemment
très important sur le petit
effectivement
vous avez raison et alors
c'est difficile de répondre de façon
très globale à ce sujet je pense que
évidemment si on étale les productions
de scorpion qu'on réduit donc les
quantités annuelles ça ira avec un
certain surcoût qui est lié à la baisse
de quantité et l'élongation du programme
et leongation aussi alors pourquoi sur
coup parce qu'il y a évidemment moyen
phénomène de volume de baisse de volume
qui peut générer des surcoûts liés à la
baisse de volume directement mais aussi
dans l'élongation puisque là on parle
quand même de durée très très longue
puisque ça si les cibles sont maintenus
ça veut dire ça nous amène à des
productions au-delà de 2030 au-delà
probablement de 2032 33 34 donc on a des
vrais sujets de gestion aussi des de la
configuration ou des de l'ensemble donc
des pièces et des composants sur des
durées aussi longues puisque un certain
nombre de ses composants risquent de
devoir être stockés pour pouvoir tenir
la la durée donc plus on étale plus plus
ça risque de d'être coûteux d'un côté et
ensuite dans votre question j'ai bien
compris qu'il y avait aussi le surcoût
lié à la au MCO à la réparation
effectivement comme je disais tout à
l'heure plus les matériels sont anciens
plus ça devient compliqué c'est pas
impossible mais ça devient compliqué et
quand on a à faire face à des de
nombreuses obsolescences je parlais de
sorte de techniques pour y faire face
mais à chaque fois ça vient avec des
surcoûts et parfois de façon assez
significative voire
limite de du raisonnable on va dire donc
c'est effectivement le sujet c'est
comment on arrive à maintenir cet
équilibre mais mais encore une fois
quand on regarde par exemple un exemple
c'est le les camions on connaît bien
ces camions j'ai baissé 180 ils ont ils
ont plus de 40 ans s'ils sont prolongés
encore 10 ans 15 ans si on retarde les
acquisition s de nouveaux matériels
c'est 50 ans 55 ans d'âge pour des
véhicules donc qui sont évidemment plus
fabriqués dans les organes sont plus
fabriqués donc il y a une il y a une
courbe de toute façon de de hausse des
coups de réparation qui est inévitable
donc plus retard et plus effectivement
il y aura des surcouches sur le la
réparation et plus on étale certains
programmes et plus rares de surco dans
la fabrication donc oui il y aura des
surcos
pardon
oui alors ça c'est le bon côté des
choses et c'est nous on en est très fier
d'ailleurs effectivement c'est des
matériaux le vape c'est pareil c'est des
matériels qui sont anciens mais qui sont
qui font le boulot qui ont évolué aussi
qui ont à qui on a donné de nouvelles
capacités donc c'est effectivement une
source de fierté aussi et d'ailleurs les
les utilisateurs ont du mal à s'en
séparer
vous avez un beau bébé maintenant dans
la cour de Balard vous avez vu
absolument
des voulait encore poser une question
juste une petite question monsieur le
Président comment se répartit votre
chiffre d'affaires par votre activité
par grande région par continent
40% déjà du chiffre d'affaires sur le
service Emco par rapport à 60% pour la
fabrication de matériel neuf déjà
ensuite la répartition entre la France
et l'export alors ça c'est très variable
d'une année sur l'autre on a eu notre
objectif c'est d'être à 55 ans en gros
d'avoir et d'ailleurs je reviendrai là
dessus sur la nécessité de l'export
d'avoir une activité équilibrée entre la
France et l'export aujourd'hui nous
pardon pardon est que représente le
continent africain pour vous alors déjà
en général l'export c'est c'est
aujourd'hui nous n'y sommes pas au 55
ans donc c'est plutôt
70-30 c'est 70 pour la France 30 pour
l'export donc on a besoin d'exporter
davantage ensuite l'Afrique ça a été ça
a été je parle pas tout à fait au passé
mais j'espère qu'il y a encore de
l'avenir mais en tout cas ça a été une
zone très importante pour nous et en
particulier pour nos ancêtres de Panhard
et Dax qui qui est d'ailleurs c'est
matériel qui sont encore très très
réputés et très demandé par les armées
africaines en revanche faut reconnaître
que depuis deux trois ans les choses
sont beaucoup beaucoup plus difficiles
évidemment liées à la relation globale
de
d'Afrique subsaharienne avec la France
le retrait de barkhane etc mais aussi
pour reconnaître aussi à la montée de la
concurrence c'est pas uniquement une
question de géopolitique concurrence
commerciale et technique de d'un certain
nombre d'acteurs vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure la Corée du Sud mais il y a
aussi des Turcs et beaucoup d'autres
concurrents émergents qui sont
extrêmement actifs en Afrique et contre
lesquels il faut se battre voilà donc
effectivement l'Afrique aujourd'hui
alors bonhomme allant c'était entre 5 et
10% de notre chiffre d'affaires il y a
encore quelques années aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup moins que ça donc c'est une
vraie source de préoccupation
bien merci monsieur le Président pour
cette communication nous essayons
régulièrement de d'avoir des contacts
avec nos industriels je pense que
effectivement nous sommes à la veille de
d'une LPM dont ni vous ni vous ni nous
ne connaissons encore le détail or nous
comprenons bientôt ce que les
industriels ont besoin de prévisibilité
pour pouvoir organiser leur chaîne de
production leur développement commercial
et la seule crainte que j'ai moi pour
l'instant des informations que je que je
recueille c'est effectivement qu'il y
ait sur un certain nombre de programmes
n'ont pas une remise en cause du chiffre
mythique de 413 milliards il a quand
même été annoncé à Mont-de-Marsan par le
Président de la République mais il peut
y avoir effectivement dans
l'organisation du temps de la LPM
2024-2030 il peut y avoir des décalages
dans le temps qui
pourrait avoir une incidence
particulièrement importante pour vous
notamment au sujet du programme scorpion
puisque c'est un bruit récurrent et que
nous voyons bien dans ta Bercy peut-être
qu'à l'hôtel Matignon une forme de
résistance à ce que la France met autant
d'argent sur la sécurité à la défense or
c'est notre rôle aussi au sein de cette
commission et de manière générale au
Parlement de faire partager par
l'opinion publique que la sécurité ça a
un prix et qu'il faut accepter de le de
d'y faire face et de le dépenser afin de
ne pas nous retrouver dans des
situations
où nous ne pourrions pas faire face à
nos engagements internationaux merci
infiniment en tous les cas pour
votre
communication et puis pour les documents
que vous nous avez montré et puis on
vous tiendra au courant et nous allons
du reste entamer immédiatement après
notre premier travail sur la loi de
programmation militaire puisque
nous avons refusé de participer au
groupe de travail à 60 ou 80
personnes qui nous semblaient pas
franchement respecter le travail
parlementaire et que nous avons
constitué nos propres groupes de
préparation à la LPM et que nous allons
avoir le premier résultat sur le 212
dans quelques instants nous rapporteurs
vont se préparer merci infiniment merci
beaucoup merci président mesdames
messieurs merci